this is a production of Cornell
University okay just to let you know the
reason I don't use powerpoints as so
many of my colleagues have been telling
me that when I use them and they just
get in the way so there are a couple of
places where powerpoints will be useful
but you all have good imagination so
we'll we'll work on that so let me to
start with I want to share with you what
one of my major concerns are now as we
think about the future and the food and
agriculture issues and as you probably
gathered from the introduction I've been
involved in sustainable agriculture now
for 40 years of my life and during that
whole time and even today still most of
my colleagues who are engaged in
sustainable agriculture are thinking
about it in terms of how do we make the
current system a little less bad and you
know whether you're into sustainability
thinking about that in terms of simply
intensifying what we're currently doing
more which is of course one school of
sustainability or if you're feeling that
everybody should go organic or if you're
feeling that what we really need to do
is become more environmentally sound
etcetera it's it's still all operating
under the notion that the basic system
we have out there the modern industrial
system is ok we just have to fix it a
little bit and my point of view is that
as we really think about sustainability
we have to think about future challenges
and that approach to sustainability is
not going to work for reasons that I'll
go into in some detail in a bit but one
of the resources that also helped me
really think about this in this kind of
transition that we need to think about
is you know the Worldwatch Institute now
publishes a state of the world report
every year and in each of they they they
choose a different theme
and the state of the world report in
2013 was entitled is sustainability
still possible and the lead essay the
lead chapter in that collection event
and that the collection of essays in my
view are always really quite good to see
but diversity of group of people that
contribute to to each of these annual
reports and and and all of the essays in
that report were good but the lead essay
was written by Robert Eagleton who at
that time was the president of the
Worldwatch Institute and he coined the
phrase for his lead essay sustained a
Babel and and and the title of the
estimate was beyond sustainable Babel
how do we get beyond sustainable and I
always thought that was a really good
way to frame this but then he pointed
out that you know we now have all these
different views of sustainability which
he says it reflects a cacophonous
perfusion of the uses of the word
sustainable to mean anything from
environmentally good to cool and he
points out that this is an approach
which has a high cost because frequent
and inappropriate use lulls us into
dreamy belief that all of us and
everything we do and everything we buy
and everything we use aren't able to go
on forever without end amen and I think
that's a really good statement about
where we are today and so this state of
dreamy belief is what we have to get
beyond and we have to really address
some of the key issues that we're facing
so one of the things that has helped me
a lot to frame this how do we now begin
to think about sustainability in a more
appropriate defensible way and one of
the resources that's been helpful to me
and in thinking about this is an
anthropologist who published a book back
in 1989 by the name of Ernest shoe ski
and the title of the book that he
published his call culture
in agriculture and ecological
introduction to traditional and modern
farming systems and as you would expect
from an anthropologist what he does is
ask the questions
how have we as humans fed ourselves ever
since we've been on the planet and
here's where a PowerPoint slide would be
useful in ethics I have one but you know
gearing everything up for that and you
all have good imagination so what I'd
like to have you think about now is the
timeline of human history so if you see
the timeline of human history all the
way across the screen here and and you
know Kooskia points out that as
full-fledged human beings we evolved on
the planet about two hundred thousand
years ago now you know you can take it
farther back than that if you want to go
back to the Neanderthals etc and a whole
million years meeting a half years
whatever but if you want to think about
it in terms of when we were what we see
ourselves as today as full-blown human
beings about two hundred thousand years
ago so he points out that for the first
two hundred thousand years the first
hundred and ninety thousand years we fed
ourselves as hunter-gatherers so if you
think of this timeline of human history
you have to go at least about halfway or
a little better than halfway across the
screen right so we fed ourselves as
hunter-gatherers and he points out that
feeding ourselves was hunter-gatherers
was the most efficient energy system
food system we ever had that we were
producing about 20 kilocalories of food
for every one kilocalorie the energy
that we invested in making that food
available to us and then about ten or
twelve thousand years ago the Argus's
when we we the Neolithic Revolution
started in which we started to do
agriculture and then instead of simply
going out into nature and hunting and
gathering what nature provided to feed
ourselves we started to manipulate
nature we started to do cultivation we
started to domesticate plants and
animals and started to feed ourselves
from that and as he points out this was
a very land intensive kind of
agriculture because we relied first of
all in the natural fertility in the soil
and then in addition to that we
primarily did the and this is not every
not every kind of agar
the majority of Agriculture was the
slash-and-burn agriculture where we
would cut down and burn the perennial
plants that were out there and then the
ash from that plus the natural fertility
would provide fertile environments in
which to grow our food for you know two
or three or four years and then we would
abandon that and slash and burn in
another place and raise our food and he
argues that from an energy efficiency
point of view this was a much less
efficient we were now only getting about
10 kilocalories of food for every kill
their calories of energy that we
invested so if you think of the timeline
of human history you go about halfway
across the screen and then probably
another two inches which is that ten
thousand years when we started to do
agriculture and then he argues and this
is the important point for the point
that I want to make here that in the
early 1900's we entered into a third era
of Agriculture which he called I think
appropriately the Neo caloric era
because it's entirely based on old
calories and then he argues that this
will have necessity be a very short
period of time in the timeline of human
history so you can think maybe a half
inch or less on that timeline of human
history and that's the agriculture that
way or that's the food system that we're
involved in now and then he points out
that this neo caloric period is the
worst energy efficient system we've ever
had we now only get about one
kilocalorie of food energy for every 10
kilocalories of energy that we invest in
making the food putting the food on our
tables and so as we think about these
old calories which support that system
as they no longer are available to us
and we have this terribly energy
intensive system we're in serious
trouble so if we really want to be
serious about sustainability this is the
picture we have to think about so that's
what I want to address with us in the
few minutes of that we're gonna have
together today I should also mention
that you know when you when you read
Ernest Nueske's view you could kind of
like you know so we were
hunter-gatherers and then one day we
woke up and said oh let's be
agriculturalists now and then one day we
Kaufmann said you know let's be Neal
caloric producers now and as Colin touch
points out in his book Neanderthals
bandits and farmers agriculture really
began that that's not the way it
happened you know it happened over a
period of time but even when we were
hunter-gatherers we started to do some
manipulations you know of nature to try
to produce more etc and even when we
shifted from the Neolithic period to the
Neo caloric create you know that didn't
farmers didn't just wake up one day and
say oh we're going to start using all
these inputs now that that happened over
a period of time probably really started
in 1841 used to solidly big you know
published his paper about how we didn't
need to involve ourselves in the
laborious process of maintaining the
health of our soil anymore all we needed
to do is put into three inputs the
nitrogen phosphorus and potassium and
then we could produce all the food that
we needed and and then it really took us
you know about half a century to really
fully adopt the Neo caloric period
but in any case this the system that we
have now is based on a paradigm which is
really true of all of the industrial
economy and that's maximum efficient
production for short term economic
return and every farmer knows that
that's what the paradigm yes he or she
has to operate under and so what that
means is that you have to think about
this in terms of how you'll accomplish
that maximum efficient production for a
short term economic return and of course
the way you do that is you specialize
because that's more efficient you
simplify your management and you go for
economies of scale and an individual who
was very much at the heart of this was
Henry Ford and some of us probably
didn't know that Henry Ford actually
grew up on a farm just outside of
Detroit and he had already been you know
adopting those principles in the farming
operation and then took those principles
when he established the first automobile
assembly line he wants families who said
that people could buy in a car they
wanted to follows was a black Ford Model
T because that was the only one he was
going to produce because that was more
efficient and then of course he didn't
teach every one of his employees to put
a whole horrible bill together taught
each one to just do a separate piece of
evidence a line and then he was
insistent on producing enough cars so
that even all of his employees could
afford to buy one that was the economies
of scale and then that concept became
adopted in agriculture and especially
after the Second World War and you know
when you drive through Iowa not for
example you don't see 40 different
varieties of crops the way we used to
grow back in the 1940s just to now just
corn and soybeans and that's it and
that's that gained that specialization
management simplification one of the
reasons that GMO crops became so popular
especially on things like soybeans is
that when you use Roundup Ready soybeans
you don't have to have all that complex
management of trying to figure out
exactly when the weeds are coming and
how you're going to control them you
just go out there and you plant your
soybeans you wait till the weeds come up
once brave Roundup and the weeds are
gone and the soybeans grow in their own
that's the simplification and then of
course the economies of scale you know
average farm sizes you know used to be
about a thousand acres in Iowa and now
we actually have 140 thousand acre farm
and a lot of the farms for five ten
thousand acres so the question we really
need to ask is whether or not this
direction that we've taken and this kind
of specialization simplification and
economies of scale continue to be
sustained into the future as we meet
these these new challenges that we're
that we're going to be facing so what
are some of those challenges well the
first challenge obviously is energy
our current system not only an
agriculture but our whole industrial
economy is absolutely dependent on cheap
energy the amount of energy that we're
currently using is unprecedented and
we've had this cheap energy because
we've had stored concentrated energy
primarily in the form of fossil fuels
when you have stored concentrated energy
all you got to do
if you expend the energy to dig into the
earth and extract that energy and then
process it and make it available and you
know back in the in the 1930s and 40s we
sometimes forget I think that the first
oil well in this country was in 1859 in
Titusville Pennsylvania said about 150
years ago and then we didn't go to the
oil economy the next day you know it
took about a you know 40 or 50 years to
really get fully into the oil economy so
we've really only been in over the
economy for about a hundred years again
a very short period of time but during
that period of time it's been these
cheap fossil fuels that have driven not
only our whole economy of especially our
food system so now and you know right
now as we all know the oil prices have
gone down but I don't need to go into
detail of why that's happening you know
it sort of didn't work out that well for
Saudi Arabia anymore so they started
producing as much as possible so this is
a short period of time in the you know
in the energy picture and at some point
these oil prices are going to go up
t-bone Pickens was an oil guy he told us
about eight years ago that we should
expect that crude oil will hit 350
dollars a barrel within ten years so we
got a couple more years to get to that
point now he probably didn't anticipate
you know the additional oil from
fracking and all of that and even if he
discount some of the ecological damage
from that etc that can't that can't
continue indefinitely under the future
so at some point the oil will be $350 a
barrel and the question I like to ask
and I spend most of my time talking with
farmers and I really prefer to talk to a
mix of farmers you know some
conventional farmers some organic
farmers some CSA farmers and market
farmers market farmers market farmers
around the same table and then instead
of getting into an argument about who's
right and who's wrong what I like to do
is to say okay let's imagine that 10
years
now crude oil would be $350 a barrel and
let's imagine that fertilizer prices are
10 times what they are today because
we're also drawing down all of our
natural resources and if you want to
read a really important book on that
Google Vardi who's now published a new
Club of Rome report called extracted in
which he goes into great detail about
all of these mineral resources and these
other natural resources on which we've
absolutely dependent where our
industrial economy are now essentially
becoming distracted and then Michael
Clare also published a book called the
race for what's left in which he also
goes into great detail on all of these
resources that we've been absolutely
dependent on in our industrial economy
are now becoming depleted and he
presents a scenario which is very
convincing that we could end up going
into a series of resource Wars to grab
those last ones that are left so we
would use the remaining resources to
fight over the resources that and you
still want to call ourselves Homo
sapiens but but nevertheless these are
all possibilities that we have to think
about and then in addition to that you
add the fact that we're drawing down our
freshwater resources all across the
planet and and of course water is
essential we're currently we're using
70% of our press to refresh water
resources just for agricultural
irrigation and part of that is because
of course we haven't paid attention to
what so ever howard reminded us we
needed to do and that was paying
attention to the biological health of
our soil so our soils don't absorb most
most of our soils now have become so
degraded they only absorb about 1/2
rench of half inch of rain water an hour
and so the rest of the water runs off
and so we have to use more irrigation
but we're drawing on a fresh readers
fresh water resources all across the
planet then of course we have to add the
big elephant in the room and that's
climate change and and all of these are
connected because climate change to some
extent is the result of the fact that we
haven't managed our natural systems in
ways that are self renewing and
self-regulating
and so we have to begin thinking now
about a future in which we you know take
all of those kinds of things into
consideration so now you can probably
come to the conclusion pretty quickly on
the ways no one said oh god it's all
going to hell with nothing we can do
about it
so I want to spend the next 15 minutes
or so talking about a different kind of
future which I think it's possible for
us and one of the things that we have
that's useful to us that we do have some
wisdom from the past about how to do
things differently in a more sustainable
way that actually can accomplish it kind
of sustainable and again we're going to
concentrate primarily on our agriculture
and food systems and one of those pieces
wisdom from the past is from Sir Albert
Howard you know Sir Robert Howard
already and he published this book an
agriculture testament back in 1943 and
he already understood back then that
this direction that useless worldly big
put us on of simply going back to using
these few synthetic inputs instead of
paying attention the biological soil
what's the wrong direction
in fact he referred to what he called
the NPK mentality he referred to that as
a form of banditry because it was going
to steal biologically healthy soils from
future generations and if this was not
conscionable and so in his book on page
four and his ideas alternative to this
it was to farm the way nature does and
on page four of the agriculture
testament he puts that concept into a
summary paragraph which is a very short
paragraph which I've always thought is a
great concept a great statement for how
we need to think about how we're going
to redesign our food system for the
future and here's how he put that he
said you know we can we can we can
summarize this in a few words and what
we need to do is to partner with nature
rather than to subdue or ignore nature
with West Jackson would put it and so
here's what he said he said mother earth
never attempts to farm without livestock
so animals are always a part of the
south
doing self-regulating system she always
yeas this mixed crops there are no
monoculture
or at least very few monocultures in
nature great pains are taken to preserve
the soil and to prevent erosion that's
how nature functions the mixed vegetable
and animal wastes are converted into
houmous and there is no waste no
everything gets recycled back into the
system in nature the processes of growth
in the process of decay balance one
another ample provision is made to
maintain large reserves of fertility and
again even since we started to do
agriculture ten thousand years ago it
was that those reserves of fertility
that we depended on for you know for
raising for producing our food the
greatest care is taken to store the
rainfall and both plants and animals are
left to protect themselves against
disease some of my colleagues take
exception to that last statement you
mean we just ignore plants and animals
we don't you know we don't attend to
their health anymore well this is not
what he's saying what he's really saying
in his view is that if you manage our
your farming systems the way nature does
then the natural immunities and health
of the animals and the plants will
pretty much take care of themselves so
you don't need to bring in resources
from outside to do that now the one
piece that's missing from his analysis
which I'm sure Wes Jackson would want to
add is that nature operates on the basis
of perennials not annuals and so if we
were to think about this concept of
Agriculture and how do we with all of
our resources that we have at our
disposal today in our modern world how
could we use those resources to create a
farming system that operates under this
principle of farming the way nature does
that I think is a is a huge challenge
for us and it's a challenge that I think
is is one that we can address and one
that we can come up with and I'll few
details on that in a bit here a second
wisdom from the past as somebody that's
all known to you here at Cornell and
that's Liberty High Bailey and among his
many publications was his book the holy
earth in which he said what we need to
do
in our agriculture system is to come up
with this new hold we have to have this
new internal motivation that helps us to
recognize that nature isn't just a
resource out there for us to exploit and
use but we have to treat it as kind of a
sacred resource and a holy earth and we
have to learn to relate to that earth in
a way that sustains its health and
vitality and the holy earth this is
again I think one of those resources
that most of us should go back and this
year 2015 is the hundredth anniversary
of the publication of that and my
understanding is that counterpoint press
is going to publish a new edition of the
holy earth and Wendell Berry is going to
write an introduction to that so we
might want to take a look at that as a
new resource you know for our students
etc and have some conversations about
again that wisdom from the past and then
you can also add to that list
Aldo Leopold who's one of my heroes and
you know the Leopold was actually
influenced by the writings of Liberty
High Bailey but even more so influenced
by his own observations of nature and
how nature function and you know he came
up with this notion that we now have to
think about the land not so much as a
commodity belonging us but as a
community to which we belong and that we
humans are simply plain members and
citizens of this biological community
that makes up this dynamic land
community and then he developed out of
that concept he developed his land ethic
but you all knows I don't need to repeat
that but then he ended up saying so how
are we going to implement this land
ethic and a land ethic isn't something
that's just written it's something that
has to be internalized in us and so he
came up with this concept of we have
what we have to do now is to develop an
ecological conscience you know a
conscience in which we all recognize
that land health is an issue that has to
be as important to us as any other kind
of ethical consideration and but how do
we develop the psychological conscience
and that's where he realized this was a
difficult task and that you couldn't
simply do this you know by writing about
it or by talking about it that this had
to be a product of
social evolution but an ecological
conscience is a conscience about land
health and land health in his view was
the lands capacity for self renewal so
how do we begin to relate to the land in
a way and buy again buy the land he
doesn't just mean the fields out there
he meant the entire biotic community how
to relate to the biotic community in a
way that it is self renewing that it and
again this is critical to how we think
about the future of our food and
agriculture system so there's some other
words you know that we could talk about
eliminate somebody just to sleep with
those three but we do have this wisdom
in the past and then we have the science
of ecology and evolutionary biology and
unfortunately in agriculture we have
applied almost none of the insights and
resources and research from the science
of ecology and evolutionary biology and
agriculture and in my view if we married
that wisdom from the past with what
we've learned from the science of
ecology and evolutionary biology I think
we could come up with incredible new
design systems for our future food and
agriculture system and that's what I'm
trying to encourage no the land-grant
university that I'm involved with and
others of us who because I think this is
a critical role which our university
community can address and when you think
about it in terms of the science of
ecology and evolution biology a couple
of things stand out not only from that
science but also from some of the things
that we're learning at the practical
level Wow is that critical in this in in
this new design of our food system is
restoring the biological health of our
soil and you have here great resources
in that in terms of Vaness who has been
working with Fred magda and others and
developing actually some metrics for how
we major soil health but we need to
really begin to address that and figure
out how we apply that and how we begin
to work with farmers and not only
farmers but other people in the food
system because if we're going to reach
if we're going to restore the biological
health of our soil we
can't continue to do maximum efficient
production for short-term economic
return we have to come up with a new
paradigm and farmers can't do that on
their own we have to all become involved
not because we have to create a new food
system and that new paradigm is more a
regenerative resilient food system for
reliable long-term return that's an
entirely different paradigm but we can
do that and we know how to do that and
if we redesigned our food system it
would encourage farmers to move in that
kind of direction and so that's so that
I think is part of what we need to what
we need to address and again we have
some interesting resources here you know
and again I don't have time to go into
all the metal but one that had really
inspired me over a long period of time
is an essay that Joe Lewis and his
colleagues and Joe Lewis was the leading
pest management specialist in the
agricultural research service for I
think almost 50 years and in 1997 he and
his colleagues published an article in a
National Academy of Sciences proceedings
and their point in their article was
after 50 years of experience he said we
now know that single tactic therapeutic
intervention strategies for solving pest
problems are not sustainable because as
they pointed out if you come if you have
a pest problem and you have this single
tactic you know you come in with a with
a pesticide the therapeutic intervention
to get rid of the pests that that's not
sustainable because what happens is you
never get rid of all the target pests so
you create pest resistance and you not
only harm the target pest but you also
harm other biological organisms some of
which previously served to help suppress
pest emergence so you're actually
causing pest resurgence so this is not a
sustainable approach and then it point
out in the middle of that article in
about three paragraphs and they said we
should not expect any other different
results from genetic engineering and we
do from chemical technology because it's
the same paradigm we're still doing
single tactic therapeutic intervention
to solve a problem rather than what they
said what we have to do now is to
transition to natural systems management
and they finally end up at the end of
that article with two questions which
I've always loved they said instead of
asking how do I get rid of the past what
we have to ask is why is the past to
past and that leads us to redesigning
the system in way that suppresses pest
emergence and that's directional I can
move in and then they argue also in
there that we aren't just talking about
pest management we're talking about you
know all of our systems that you know
whether you're a farmer or whether
you're a schoolteacher or whatever if
you're addressing your task as a single
tactic therapeutic intervention you're
really not enabling people to understand
what's going on in the system that's
causing the problem in the first place
and that's the direction we have to move
in so I think this is a brilliant
article that I hope everybody and it's
still all you got to do is Google Joe
Lewis and and and and the article will
come up and you can download it and and
read it one of the other things that has
inspired me recently is Dan barber who's
a good friend of mine who's the chef
actually and many of you I'm sure know
him or know about him he has two
restaurants in New York and I actually
wanted to own barber or I spent part of
my time and one in town and Dan's
published a new book now called the
third plate and he argues as a chef now
based on his experience that the
farm-to-table direction we went from you
know industrial food production to the
farm-to-table food production and that
was an important transition but we need
to go beyond that now because what he
discovered is that as a chef of course
what he's primarily concerned about is
getting that kind of quality of food
which has this exceptional taste that
satisfies his customers and along the
way he discovered that as a chef the
easiest way to accomplish that is to
find the farmers who manage their soil
for soil health because if you grow food
on soil that has healthy that's healthy
soil then you have food that has this
incredible taste quality and as a chef
all you need to do is prepare this food
in a way that allows the natural
to express yourself you don't have to do
all the manipulation to get the food to
do what you wanted to do and then of
course and Dan is also very interested
when a farmer farms in a way that gets
this kind of by lots of healthy soil
what does the farmer have to do so he
starts to visit the farms and one of the
key relationships that he had was to
Klaus Martens he was actually pretty
close to you here and OH and Klaus
Martens was producing a variety of Emmer
wheat that was out of this world and
says what the unwanted and so he went to
Klaus his farm to see what Klaus was
doing in order to produce this Emeril
weed and he discovered that Klaus had to
grow some cover crops from which he got
no income he had to have a crop rotation
which included the millet and barley
which there was no market in the food
market so he had to sell that as animal
feed which he got less money for and
then suddenly Dan realized what he was
doing is simply cherry picking this one
product from his farm for his own
benefit just like going into a
supermarket and just cherry picking some
things and that was not the future of
the food system what we have to learn
now is the what he called eating from
the whole farm so he started to work
with Klaus and they figured out ways
that they could harvest some of the
leafy material from the cover crops
which he could use in his salads in the
restaurant and he started to design some
menus or some of some items and his menu
made from the millet in front of the
barley so he could actually buy those
his food crops from from Klaus and this
then suddenly quit Klaus into a much
better economic situation in this
concept now of eating from the whole
farm is becoming popular even in Iowa
listen people say you know we've got to
deal with farmers differently here we
got to think about what farmers have to
do what we want them to do and then how
do we reward for them for that in the
marketplace and this is a whole new
concept which is going to take some time
I'm sure to catch on every wealth but if
it's catching on in Iowa catch on
anywhere so
so these are the kinds of directions and
again we could there so let me also add
one other little bit of good news here
that's happening and that's actually in
the business world because obviously
people in the business world have to
begin to transform their operations as
well and there are two resources I'm
going to call to your attention and one
is an article that was published in the
Harvard Business Review the January
February 2011 issue by Michael Porter
and Mark Kramer who are two of our
leading economists which is important to
keep in mind here and they wrote this
article entitled creating shared value
and that article was written to the
business community and basically what
they said in the article of creating
shared value they said if we continue if
people in business continue to operate
by what they call the old playbook
you're not going to be successful in the
future and operating by the old playbook
is getting your labor and your raw
materials as cheaply as possible so you
can increase your profits in your
company and externalizing as much of
your environmental costs in your social
cost as possible to increase your profit
in your own company and if you're going
to continue to operate by that old
playbook you're not going to be
successful in the future the reason is
because our labor and raw materials are
now becoming so degraded you're not
going to have the quality of those labor
and raw materials who they contend to be
successful in your business and you
could continue to externalize your
environmental costs and your social
costs then your social and natural
capital in your community is going to
deteriorate to a point where not to be
able to have a successful business in
those communities so you now have to
figure out how you're going to do
business on the basis of shared value
taking all of these considerations these
issues into consideration in your
business plan and they make a very
compelling case for this and I know that
Michael Porter at least is now doing
some workshops around the country with
people in the business community trying
to help them understand why they need to
make this kind of transition and then
there's a second resource which i think
is in many ways is equally important and
this is a
his name is Andrew Winston he has
started his own company au which he uses
as a consulting firm to work with major
corporations especially in the
agriculture and food system and the
title of his book is the big pivot and
the subtitle is radical practical
strategies for a hotter scarce er and
more open world and his point in his
book is that if you're in business and
you want to be successful in the future
you can't just kind of you know make
things a little less bad and hope that
you can be successful because we're now
in a situation where we have a hotter
world that's the effects of climate
change which we're already affecting our
businesses and we'll continue to do so
for in the future we're living in a
scarce er world where many of these
resources that I've talked about are no
longer gonna be there so you have to
figure out how you're gonna redesign
your business to operate under those
circumstances and it's a more open world
so if you think you can work your way
through this simply with a better job of
messaging you're on the wrong side of
history because there are now the social
media and if you if you put out that
kind of message and it's not true
somebody will come up with a ten minute
video to expose you and then it's gonna
hurt your business so you now have to
make a big pivot turn and fundamentally
rethink and reorganize your system again
he makes a very compelling case for this
so these things are happening in the
business world as well as in the you
know in the physical world and I think
there's some other things we could talk
about here but we can maybe we'll get
into the Med questionnaires but I want
to I want to end with one other thing is
that is I think the role that the arts
can play in all of this because if we
can't imagine a different way of doing
things in a better future and become
emotionally energized to do that it's
going to be very difficult to see how
we're going to make these big pivot
turns and I want to give you just one
example of the way in which the arts can
be so effective Kathleen Dean Moore who
is the head of the philosophy department
at Oregon State University and she told
me once that when she got into the field
of philosophy we had to realize that
philosophers often use such dead
language they don't even understand each
other let alone the general public and
she didn't want to be a part of that
world so she started to translate these
important philosophical concepts into
stories and in her book the Pine Island
paradox at one point where she talks
about the difficulties and challenges
his in and and damage that we're doing
with our wars and with the way in which
we're treating our environment etc this
simply can't go on so she decides to
imagine her daughter her granddaughter
writing her a letter from a hundred
years in the future and what would she
say to her and here is here's the story
here's the imaginary letter that she
puts out which I think is a great
example of how the arts can be used in
such a powerful way she imagines her
granddaughter saying how could you not
have known what more evidence that you
need that your lives your comfortable
lives would do so much damage to ours
did you think that you could wage war
against nations without waging war
against people and against the earth
didn't you wonder what we would drink
once who had poisoned the aquifers
didn't you wonder what we would breathe
once who had poisoned the air did you
stop to ask how we would be safe in a
world poisoned by war did you think that
it all belonged to you this beautiful
earth you who loved your children did
you think that we could live without
clean air in healthy cities you who love
the earth did you think that we could
live without birdsong and swaying trees
and if you knew how could you not care
what could matter to you more than your
children and their babies how could a
parent destroy what is life-giving and
astonishing in her child's world and if
you knew and if you cared how could you
not act what excuses did you make and
now what would you have us do and I
think this is a powerful kind of
statement which can serve to energize us
you know because it's our grandchildren
that's going to inherit the world that
we're creating and so we need to begin
to take seriously these kinds of
transitions that we have to make not
only in our food and agriculture system
but
that's critical because we can do
without a lot of things in the future
but we can't do without food in the
water and so so this is what I wanted to
leave with you today and go to some love
day you'll have your concept and I
always say to people I'm especially
interested if I said something you
disagree with because I'm a Russian
German so I haven't had an argument I
haven't had a good day yet so but anyway
let's say what helped and then Matt's
going to repeat the question so yeah
it's on us to do more sustainable
farming or go to the farmers what do you
think the world does the corporate
farming clean the United States how does
that have to change in the future
because essentially part of the problem
is corporate farming and they manipulate
the farmers
yeah well that's part I didn't graduate
because we all become part of the
economy the culture which sustains back
and Paul Roberts leasing and quality and
Paul society and we came into very
compelling case for the fact that the
kind of culture that we live in now is
all about mine and now and of course our
corporate world also lives by that
culture of interest so so we have this
kind of economic system
each of us feel we have to
and of course corporations corporations
don't wake up one day and say I'm a
human system that's able to say pop
tonight you know how can I create my
business give me the most profit that
means you have to play out to that kind
of
so how do we think culture how do we
change the cultural issues that's it
that's a problem I don't think that's
going to happen from the top down these
are changes to the bottom up and okay
one of the things that's encouraging to
the engineers there's a body of
literature now that's coming out which
is helping us to understand that these
cultural transitions needs to take place
Paul Roberts does a much better job
describing the problem that because
coming up with an answer but
nevertheless complexities in some
direction
but aren't you Kelly tokido book a few
years ago called owning our future she
makes a very compelling case that
there's economy ee and now which he
calls the extractive economy each of us
try to grab as much as possible that's
not at least I didn't come in to this
function again you don't have all the
resources and keep that
and you've got these concentrations of
wealth that leave so many people out of
it it doesn't serve the community and
it's starting to evolve times which he
calls the generative economy where
people in communities are starting to
work together or what she calls the
common flourishing of life to give some
practical examples of you know the kinds
of things that are starting to happen in
various places so I think if we can
begin to point to some of these
generative economy emergence and some of
them are having a connect repulsion she
points out that you know we're groups of
farmers pool their production and have
their own brand and establish these
relationships with their customers no
electric Bali and Shepherds grain and
not to branch they're actually now
much more successful than the
that's one example the aggregation on
harvest now 58.3 negra change of
requirements and each of these hold a
values based value chains together so I
think as we start to see that there is a
success pattern that was in this other
direction that actually is more based on
the common good and the generative
economy that's common flourishing flight
that that actually works better than
where each of us trying to defend
ourselves and that could begin to kick
us in the direction of changing changing
our culture I'm not saying that's going
to happen tomorrow but it's already
happening at some place
I'm not trying to be cynical I agree
with everything you're saying but I I
just forget about the political economy
new ties power and to do this at scale
and I don't see the incentives for
business or the politicians that they
fund to really change our even though
it's necessary so we've seen yet we're
really struggling to actually make
significant policy changes to university
course it was huge momentum to keep
everything the way that it is related to
the food system related urbanization and
our power structures so how do we
grapple with that instead we've got a
really important question and I
but here's the other thing that I think
we need to pay attention you know in our
current system which obviously still
working for certain segments of the
economy and if it weren't working for
corporations anymore but you know Ken if
you start to look at the early
indicators those changes that are taking
place
here just give you a couple of examples
Cargill Corporation has one of the
biggest defenders of GMOs in our food
system and have contributed to not
having any labeling and says they've not
come out with
Hershey corporation made a decision here
the police ago that they're on the
transition to the concoction--
why are they doing
they're consuming public was
increasingly saying we see some changes
and inclusive now the important factors
were power particles the important thing
about all of this is that if you're in
the food business do custom food
customers have a lot more power than if
you again or local manufacturing or
community because in fact we had a
property extension individual in Iowa
did a research project this was like 10
years ago and she made a case for the
fact that she thought that food
customers have much more power than any
because if you're a company and you're
producing automobiles or computers as
she put it and if you lose a couple of
customers you might always get your
existing customers to upgrade or finance
sector car or second here in the food
business and you lose your customer
so people in the food business have a
lot of power so when she did and of
course that she was teaching she asked
her students to do a research project
she asked the students to go to
supermarkets and find out how many
people had a go into the supermarket and
asked the manager for a particular
product that they wanted in the same
week or how long would it take in order
for that to start what they found
without exception was that 15 students
when it's the same supermarket and asked
the manager she used that as an example
of the power so appears might be I
believe we reviewed that today
our hoods are the input supplier
processors all the way huge investments
in the current system and they make huge
investments in the current system
because we all said what we wanted to
water food fast convenient achievement
that's exactly it
now that they've invested billions
dollars the Lord said you know we'd like
to make some changes everything
well it's not going to happen right but
what is happening in can happen is that
instead of us going to them and saying
we like to have exchanges is be working
together in our
more customers that say this is what we
want this is Tiffany it's beginning to
happen particularly in our urban centers
where there is this evolution of what I
call food citizens you know bill
Heffernan who is retired now the people
in sociology professor have been the
University of Missouri
he's I think done more research than
anybody else on the concentration in the
retail food systems and how it's that
concentration between control you have a
large number of people in our urban
population centers eventually to these
glowing populations
then we'll have the possibility I think
or some changes taking place
in the meantime we've gotta be
concentrating working with people
two quick comments one is I think I've
really enjoyed your talking more about
the u.s. continent very much in South
Asia where issues are just the same more
fun but one of the people who didn't
mention the sax Department and I always
put in my lectures that we've got to
produce the food using resources more
efficiently we have to minimize the
effect on the environment but we've got
to maintain the likelihoods people
actually produce the food and we all
want cheap food cheap cheap food is a
political thing and if we don't pay the
farmers a fair price for their labor
we're going to have more more fungus
leaving leaving the area going to the
urban areas like like you see in India
and China and then what happens now
another really great question and and
you're right
I was working primarily on Earth
again part of the good news from my
perspective the most ardent happen
more of a recognition that for them to
adopt the industrial system that we have
in the industrial world is not certain
we should talk about some pressure
points plan to bring that system to
farmers in the developing world but
there's a rapidly growing phenomenon how
farmers themselves are beginning to
recognize that way it would they can be
successful in the future
and there's also not five UN reports
that confirm this that is that you want
to be really address the issues of money
after women
secondly
have to work with them in terms of their
local resources and social capacity so
these are these are things whatever the
encompassing ideal through the Via
Campesina movement
some people hear that
23 years old but he yes he has started a
nonprofit organization
he just got back last week I'm spending
I took four weeks in India six weeks in
Egypt and in his full approaches he
knows that there are individual farmers
in each of these countries already
figured this out doing this and so he
wants to try to connect other farmers
with those farmers something to get to
approach this
training
so again I think there's some things
that we can do but and then eventually
you know Lauren you're saying this is
not only the future developing for
adulthood potential
so you're absolutely right I didn't mean
to exclude a car the only reason that I
put the emphasis where it is today is
that so often groups of people who think
this is simply a farmer problem we
simply gotta convince the farmers they
need to make these changes and I want to
help us to understand this is a social
issue
yeah so the focus on obviously
production systems are focused on the
provisioning system services but the
other ecosystem services that don't get
a lot of attention some farmers are
actually supporting those
is there a way to compensate or minimize
other services that are not getting
bored of course yeah and we actually
have a few small programs that
Conservation Corps has better try to
address that but it's such a minor part
you know a lot of these challenges that
I talked about there are significant
holes
- regret with relatively minor
but again
if I do it's going to be pretty much
lots of applause I think again we're
going to be able to convince people at
the National
that because they're under constant
pressure from the best interest to keep
their assistant so I think we haven't
agreed this
and this is why my point about power
right so there here is the pressure from
I think that better wait not that we
should ignore
the natural
tradition
exactly
affective support them
long-term
yes so a lot of us are scientists who
were all about their science that
changes the technologies that you know
like the interaction system
potentially they could change the
production systems in ways they awarded
much that meant to Rory did live work to
be more attractive at the outset which
which way we're going
I mean select to my daughter from the
peach my granddaughter to the teacher
who is right and asked me why do not
match I would say well I'm doing my best
right experiment sort of think about the
direction that science yeah great
question
try to reduce that and for me
I want to romanticize
but there is a growing population
they recognize this is their future
a couple
always
they would don't want to
shop
these two kid
this is what this is what next
a little important
then
and if their parents who are already
part of this millennium
recognized
that's what
future
do you know I would tell people when I
my first American history course first
day of our class
teacher
I want you all to understand that only
20% of the American colonists were in
favor of the American Revolution at
least I want you to understand that
because the reason you should study
history instead of learning from the
past probably apply the lessons from the
past future so he said if any of you are
interested bring it on changes you don't
need understand
and always remember that you know as I
think about this millennial generation
now with these different
but I do know
old age whatever involvement
State University Law Center other places
I've been
keep running it
these young people
there are so many of them at least I
take again great inspiration from that
my responsibility
I don't have a better answer to your
question than that
again the fact that this already
happened
support
indicator
so I think we're already over time a
little bit I think looking here for a
couple minutes so if we want to just
break down and thank for it again and
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu